Molly's nightmare began in 2012. Rebels
rampaged through the North
islamist militants destroyed sacred
shrines
together they terrorized innocence and
Unleashed years of insecurity and
instability
the United Nations with around 1 000
German peacekeeping troops stepped in to
stabilize the country
but with mixed results
what we see quite some years down the
line is that the situation remains dire
that the
overall conflict environment remains uh
extremely severe in Malibu now the UN
Mission looks stalled first France
withdrew
then Britain and Ivory Coast
now Germany will leave
so is Germany turning its back on Mali
or is there more to it
situation deteriorated after a military
coup in 2020. followed by another one
just months later she essentially
brought to power Military Officers who
well who are committed or claimed to be
committed to stabilizing the country but
who have taken a very different approach
to how that should be done
the new Junta rulers made life difficult
for their un guests refusing to Grant
flight permits German forces based at
Camp caster and GAO were basically left
sitting on their hands
so the partnership between Western
countries and the Malin government has
considerably collapsed with alliances
shifting Mali turned to an old friend in
Moscow
and in particular with a private
military contractors from Russia which
of course has
made it much more difficult for Western
countries with a specific kind of
commitment to to democratic values to
support
this new
setup
the German foreign minister confronted
Himalayan counterpart over the issue
we cannot continue to work together if
there is no distancing from Russian
forces
her appeal fell on their fears the
situation in Mali is the situation in
Mali and we hope that each of mali's
Partners will respect mali's choices
Mali makes its choices according to its
concerns just as Germany makes its
choices according to its concerns
actually offers something of a
like-minded uh setup in terms of the
country so you know um we're talking
about stakeholders who who value the
figure of the so-called strong man as a
leadership figure
it now means Germany's two billion Euro
mission is all but over bundesfair
soldiers responsible for providing
Technical and reconnaissance support
will pull out by may 2024. we should be
aware that this is it is a moment in
time and decisions made now out of
frustration with the government of Mali
will have a real impact on roughly 22
million people living in Mali and all
the neighbor States
but is Germany really leaving Mali in
the lurch
Germany's not turning its back on Mali
because obviously the German military
engagement is one of several ways of
contributing to Mali and if we look at
Development Corporation if we look at
the work of critical foundations like
ours we are still present and we will
stay present Berlin's Retreat comes amid
growing security fears at home since
Russia's invasion of Ukraine on the one
side we have to step up our efforts for
Collective defense and National Defense
on the other side we have to remain
committed to International crisis
management that's what we are doing
right now that's why the German
government and the German Parliament in
total will remain committed to
stabilizing the sahia zone for example
that commitment had always been called
into question
when German forces do eventually go home
it will draw the line under an ugly
chapter but with reports of violence
spreading it's unlikely to be the end of
mali's troubles